it was here the place where their
children learned and lived that their
mothers met
the families of both Barnaby Miller and
Grace O'Malley Kumar came to share
support and hold each other tight
two students were both 19 years old
their lives filled with energy and
opportunities
but everything stopped early on Tuesday
morning when they were stabbed to death
as they made their way home after a
night out in Nottingham
their fathers wanted to speak to the
thousands standing silently on campus
I've lost my baby boy
and I can't
even comprehend how I'm going to do and
deal with it myself and Emma and
Charlene
this family and friends
well I know but it would be super
touched by everyone that's here
and he he loved it he loved it here he
couldn't wait to come back the love that
we have out here are just
reacted everywhere
so
look after each other
it's the big thing
is that
look after your friends
and look after people around you
relatives of the third victim of the
attacks were also here at the vigil Ian
coats was a school caretaker a devoted
Grandad who was soon due to retire
another innocent victim
they laid hundreds of single stems
family
teammates
friends
and University staff
what should have been one of the biggest
celebrations for student
s should have turned into one of our
Darkest Days Grace had represented
England at hockey for the under 16 and
under 18 age groups she was a huge
talent and she was a medical student who
volunteered to give people vaccines
during the pandemic
Barnaby from Taunton in Somerset was
also excelling at Sports and his history
studies
his university cricket team just one of
the many places where he felt right at
home Barney was enthusiastic it's
incredible he's such a handsome bloke as
well it's just it's hard for me to say
but he was just a great bloke he threw
himself into everything every social he
was the every training session every
match supporting playing he was always
there it was amazing grace was
incredibly well known as well as she was
she was incredibly well known she was um
I have many mutual friends in the hockey
club and around and no one can speak
hardly enough of her as well the
families had traveled many hours to be
here but right now in this shared moment
of grief
they didn't want to be anywhere else
Tom Parmenter Sky News Nottingham